so today for our daily cancellation
we're going to cancel everybody involved
in the impeachment efforts
efforts currently underway in the house
uh the articles of impeachment released
last night charged donald trump with
incitement of insurrection and other
crimes as well now usually the daily
cancellation
is reserved for things that aren't very
serious this is a time for content
that's
maybe a bit more farcical than the rest
of the show and and that's
in fact actually why it's a good place
to discuss the democrats second
impeachment of trump
which is indeed a farce unserious a
political stunt
so here are the problems with impeaching
trump as far as i can see
at least two of the problems first of
all no matter what you think of the fact
that trump was
claiming voter fraud and the fact that
he called for a rally in dc and the fact
that he you know sent the crowd over to
the capitol building
you can't get around uh the fact that
that trump
did specifically call for a peaceful
protest
in his remarks of the crowd you could
check the transcript i have
and here's what the transcript says
here's what he said
we have come to demand that congress do
the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building to
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard
that's what he said now you might argue
that he didn't really mean it you might
argue that he didn't really care what
would happen
you can argue all that you might be
wrong you might be right but
the fact still remains that he did
explicitly and verbally call for a
peaceful protest
we have seen lawmakers encourage
violence
and riots explicitly we know what that
sounds like
the democratic state representative in
michigan a few weeks ago we played that
clip
calling on quote-unquote soldiers to
find trump supporters and quote make
them pay
okay that if trump had said to the crowd
find these lawmakers and make them
pay okay now you got a case
that is obviously incitement
ayanna presley during the blm riots
calling for
more quote unrest in the streets
once again if trump had said go to the
capitol building and there needs to be
unread if he had said there has to be
unrest at the capitol building in order
to
prevent this from happening once again
you have a case
alexandria ocasio-crest cortes blasting
the people who called for an end to the
unrest
claiming that to call for an end to the
unrest is to call for
injustice to continue that's what she
said maxine waters telling her
supporters to track down trump
administration officials in public and
to create a crowd and let them know they
aren't welcome anywhere those are direct
quotes
all of these and much more are examples
of explicit incitement
direct incitement and as it happens
all of the people guilty of it now
support impeaching trump for allegedly
doing
what they unquestionably have done
themselves
um if you want to argue that it's
incitement
simply to get a potentially unruly crowd
riled up with dubious claims and to send
them out to
sort of broadly fight for this or that
then again
the democrats behind this impeachment
would be guilty of the same
even the ones who didn't explicitly
endorse rioting were still
spreading the false claims that fueled
the riots and encouraging the rioters to
continue the
fight for social justice so
before the democrats can even begin to
make a case for impeachment
all of those guilty of doing these
things
would need to admit their guilt and
resign
that's what they would have to do do
that first here's the deal that i would
make
if i had any power at all which i don't
uh do that first
if you're a democrat and you were guilty
of incitement yourself by your own
standard guilty of it
by the standard you're now applying to
trump if you did it yourself
resign and then i'm willing to listen to
the impeachment case
from the three or four democrats who
remain in office
that should be the deal if the
republicans had any sense
any backbone any spine that's what they
would be saying
they should be saying absolutely let's
let's let's get rid of everybody
who's been guilty of inciting riots
during this time of chaos and anarchy
uh because it's it's it's enough we have
to put an end to it
um so let's get rid of all of them and
let's start with you guys
that's what they should be saying second
point all that aside
um or not aside but at least uh you know
i i make this point as an important
addition to the previous donald trump is
out of office
in a week seven days that's it
he'll be gone regardless and i would bet
everything i own that trump
is not going to run again in 2024 at the
age of 78 after all of this
i mean he may say he will he maybe he
may make noises to that effect over the
next four years but
i don't think he's really going to do it
so this is not even an effort to remove
him from office
because he's going to be gone before the
senate trial can begin and i don't buy
that this is about stopping him from
running again
in fact i think the democrats would love
for trump to run again
they're terrified of the prospect of
having to exist now on their own
without being able to define themselves
by their opposition to trump
they can't even remember what it was
like to have a political ideology that
wasn't defined by trump
so this isn't about removing him
from office because again he'll already
be gone and it isn't about stopping him
from running again
this is rather symbolic it is theater
it is impeachment as theater and it's
not the first time the democrats have
done it
the people who have pretended to be so
concerned about norms and about
protecting the democratic system and
so on have now turned impeachment which
is an essential tool
into a meaningless empty gesture
two presidents in nearly 250 years had
been impeached before trump
the democrats have now impeached trump
twice
in almost a year meaning they've done it
as many times
in a year as every congress in history
had done it before this
they have doubled the number of
impeachment in in a year they've doubled
it
so that means it's been cheapened the
the the tool of impeachment has been
cheapened
to the point of uselessness
this means now is that um impeachment
will be used
commonly if the opposing party controls
the house
uh it'll be used just to make a
political point because that's what it's
become now
what was once rare what was once nearly
unthinkable
will now be utterly commonplace a matter
of course
you know we had we have now four
impeachments in 20 250 years it was two
now we have four
the next 20 years we'll probably see
that many we'll probably double it
another 20 years
if not more because of
what they've done with this tool of
impeachment
and again an essential tool now it means
nothing
because of what democrats have done
because they are using it
as just symbolism
and that's why um i think we should all
be opposed to impeachment no matter how
you feel about trump
that's why we should all be posted and
that's why the democrats are canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated